- Hanging out with all my
best friends in my head.
(laughter)
I'm the biggest fan of the show.
- I was gonna say, are
you a Housewives Fan?
- Oh, it's beyond that.
It's, I'm actually moderating
their BravoCon panel
this weekend in Vegas.
- Oh My God. -Yeah.
- We're partying! (crowd cheering)
- We're partying.
We're already planning
like (dinner, drinks) spots
of a strip to hit up, you know.
- Wait, speaking of Strip,
you were, you went to my show?
- Yes, I did.
- I was like, you said you were gonna come
and then I didn't know if
you really would. You did.
- Oh, no, I was on top of it.
I bought tickets to your
last show of the residency.
(That was fun) because I knew
that was the one that
was really gonna give.
I was like, they were all gonna give,
but I was like, I know
that you're gonna whip out the classics.
Is is that me sobbing
at your show? (laughter)
- Is that the one? Wait,
is that the one that
I did Happier than ever? Is that the
- You did Happier than
Ever, you did Sober.
- Yeah. That's for real fans.
- Uh, yeah. And then you
did, I didn't know this,
but, so I had of course
memorized the set list
before we got, by the way,
I brought like 13, 14 of my friends.
I'm not kidding. We went as
an gay army to your show.
So we went and I had like
memorized the set list
and I knew at the end when you were gonna
stop before the encore.
So I was like, I can go to
the bathroom. At this theater,
the men's room was in
Timbuktu. I'm going and I hear
just, what if I told you?
And I'm like, she's not
doing a Moment Like This.
She had never done a Moment Like This.
- I never do a Moment like This. -Really?
- She surprise did A
Moment Like This. (Yeah)
I peed faster and harder
(laughter)
- And then you were running back
- And I was sprinting back and
also it's like you're pretty,
let's say hydrated when you're in Vegas.
You know what I Oh my God.
Mean there was a lot of stuff
that was drunk, so I had to go so bad.
But I was like, let me make it
back for a moments like this.
And then I got there and I sobbed.
- I love the video. I know you're so
- I was really crying hard.
- I mean anytime you sing, I cry.
- Oh my gosh. Well I never, I never sing
that one. Generally just, yeah,
- I know and that's why I was so surprised
you were doing it, because I
know you traditionally don't.
(Yeah) And so then I was like, come on.
I'm literally at the urinal
- The one time you go to pee
- Screaming to my friend
Patrick, like, we have
to go, we're not washing our hands.
(laughter)
- Like it was, I'll
cop to being unhygienic
when it comes to getting
back to the seats.
- Oh, if I'm running
back in somewhere. Yes.
- Yeah. No, it's just,
- Or it's usually my kid at a movie.
They're like, I've got a pee.
I'm like are you serious?
- Yeah, I know. But you put
on such an incredible show.
- Oh, thanks.
- I mean obviously it
was you guys, you're,
you are adding new shows, right?
- But you, we are. That's
announced, right? Yes.
Yes. We are. We did. We added a,
a couple, I think. But I was like,
I'm always like, what am
I allowed to talk about?
I always forget.
Well wait, I wanna talk
about your Christmas album.
So wait, did you, you did this special,
I remember you were saying,
yeah, I just wanna do it.
I'm gonna go out there
and do a Christmas song.
- It started as a bit fully,
I fully hacked the system
and got a record deal.
So I, as a joke in 2017, I'm a comedian.
I came up here in New York City
and I was just looking
to put like a new show up
and I was like, oh, I
think I saw an interview
with Mariah Carey and the interviewer was
like, this is so great.
Like every year you have a lot to do.
You have a full schedule. I was like,
I would like something to do every year.
Maybe I'll do a Christmas album.
- I remember you saying this to me. (Yeah)
- And literally I made it up.
I was like, yeah, I'm
doing my Christmas album at
the Duplex in the West Village. - Stop.
- People came, they loved
it. Every year I added to it.
Now I have a fully original, it's pop,
(crowd cheering)
it's comedy and it's Christmas.
It's coming out on Capitol
Records, baby. - That's so cool.
- I mean, it's unreal. And like I worked
with Leland, who's this amazing producer.
He is worked with Troy
Sivan, Carrie Underwood,
Selena Gomez, Kelsey
Ballerini. He did like
- Never heard of any of those people.
- Yeah, right. (ha ha ha)
Just some no names. (Yeah)
But like fully, he produced
my whole album and now,
I mean,
- Look at where life takes
you. - It's insane. - Yeah.
- And so that's why I'm
saying like, you have
to fake it till you make
it for real in the biz.
- I say it is manifestation.
You gotta put it out there.
- It really is.
- 'cause I literally said the words,
I have an album as a joke.
(Wow.) Seven years later.
I mean you just,
- And then you do have an album
- Look right there. Look
at that. By the way,
- Look at that handsome devil.
What album cover.
- Thank you.
We were going for like
an Elvis Presley vibe.
We wanted like a very
traditional look to contrast
with the very modern content.
- Yeah, but that's what's,
- It's from my lens,
which is not necessarily
like Silver Bells,
it's more like
- Silver Balls.
- Yeah, Silver Balls. (ha ha ha)
- But by the way, so Kelly is always
so thoughtful in the gift that you give
you are the best by the way.
Because the, she gives every guest
the vinyl. She's really thoughtful,
- I trying to guess like who,
but I know that you like
Mariah. 'cause we talked
about Mariah for some time.
- So you came on Bow and I's
podcast, Loves La Theresas
and we all like, (gushed)
were I go Mariah,
because we're all in the Lamily, right?
- Yes. - And so she gifted me
today. You did the best. You,
you gave me Mariah's debut album.
- I did. - Wow!
- And so my gift to you
is you can have that.
(laughter)
Kelly Clarkson, you can take that home.
- I love it. (crowd cheering)
I love that you have a
Christmas record. Four
more shows. We, I know.
I wasn't sure we announced the other two.
That's why I did like, (No, you did)
- I can confirm.
- I was like was there
the two or four. Okay.
- On your socials, all your shows
are announced. You can talk about them.
- Totally and I totally posted that.
(laughter)
So we need another break.
Matt's album is called,
Have you heard of Christmas?
It's out Tomorrow.